joining me now once again is Marwan
Bashar Al jaer a senior political
analyst um so as we discuss this deal um
we got an idea just there with with with
that graphic we showed of what is St at
stake for uh the Palestinians as they
see this uh from from their
side well clearly this will be a bit of
a break uh from the war and uh to be
honest uh we've been talking now for
something like 46 days about why this is
not like like any other War right this
is not a war between two states this is
not a war between two armies this has
unraveled as a war on hospitals and
schools and mosques and residential
buildings on doctors and teachers and
nurses and
journalists this is the kind of War it's
been and that's why to have few days of
that kind of War I'm sure it will be a
relief for many of the people uh whether
they are patients in hospitals where
there are children at home just want to
have one
night of sleep without
bombings um in that way it is certainly
uh welcomed uh and necessary and and
clearly the release of uh um prisoners
held captives basically in Israeli
prisons uh old women and and others for
so many years many of them without even
trial indefinitely as well absolutely
that's also um welcome and I think the
idea of getting those uh trucks of uh
medicine and food and some fuel that's
also welcome because the idea of
starving a population is absolutely the
definition of a genocide when you cut
electricity and basically starve a
population you're not being civil you're
being criminal in this war so all of
that is welcome but when you listen to
the Israelis you get the sense that it's
absolutely unwelcome I mean with
the with the exception of certain uh
members of the public who have family
members held by Hamas when you listen to
the Israeli officials it seems like this
is just a bit of an exception a bit of a
glitch that as soon as it's over you
know few days five six days later that
they will resume their war in fact
listening to prime minister Netanyahu
speaking in uh earlier today he says
already that the invasion of Kan Yunis a
city of 400,000 people almost probably
doubled by now because of the war will
be invaded and it's not a question of
when it's a it's not a question of if
it's a question of when and probably
expect it to be again in the next few
days so Israel in some ways while it's
presenting us as if they're making
decisions in some form of institutions
of a state but they the Israelis have
been acting more like a tribe A hateful
vengeful violent tribe against basically
a people the Palestinians and for 46
days carrying those sorts of war crimes
against them which really is just been
so inhumane once again uh just to have a
few days of a bit of a perhaps relative
humanity would be welcomed could that be
something to build on for the future and
then also
uh the fact that there will be uh many
other Israeli families who will not see
their family members released in this
particular deal and so they will be
continuing to put pressure on the
Israeli government going forward so
that's the hope uh on the part of for
example the kataris who have mediated
this that certainly would be the hope of
many of the Israeli families I think
also the Palestinians of course would
like to see uh those humanitarian poses
truths whatever uh EX transformed into
extended ceasefires and eventually and
that's my perspective on this because
today we were just talking about
captives and and poses for me this
entire war is illegal is Criminal this
war needs to end the war needs to end
not some ceasefire here and there not
sort of extend the poses not you know
beg the Americans to interfere when they
are complicit in their War when they are
enabling the war crimes here not to you
know appeal to the Europeans who are
again complicit in this war enabling
this war to continue while playing the
humanitarians showing up at the ra
Crossing with Egypt in order to check
the goods as if they are the
humanitarian when they are in fact
complicit in the war crimes so this
entire Enterprise of War making against
a people who have been under occupation
for 56 years under
siege under criminal siege for the past
70 years
this must end but we are somehow all of
us wrapped up in this logic as if war is
the norm war is not the norm occupation
is not the norm Siege is not the norm
killing thousands upon thousands of
civilians is not the norm killing 5,000
children is not the norm so the idea
that this should be just a rest spite so
that we can continue the killing of
children bombing hospitals and mosque
besieging schools and bombing them from
the air that should not be the norm the
International Community needs to wake up
and Israel's enablers in Western
capitals need to wake up and not you
know flap themselves on the shoulder
saying oh we did a good job because we
have five days of humanitarian pose it's
criminal it's inhumane and the entire
war must
stop senior aler political analyist
Maran Bish thank you